similarly the brain does the same thing
I mean you start learning you know there
are only one to nine numbers so you
start adding one to nine and units and
then suddenly you say oh well if I add
nine and four that's more than nine now
where does that what happens to that so
then you learn about tens and then you
learn about hundreds and you learn about
thousand you know and so on that you
know so all these things happened I mean
unfortunately the system has kind of
come up with these thirteen years of
learning K to twelve are officially
because you have different kids going at
different rates to learn and did we get
the aha moment faster or slower than
others and yet you know we kind of keep
them in this okay so because I can tell
that we're about to get into a little
bit of the personalization and the dab
of technology that you've built yes and
I want will we're gonna get there I want
to keep us for one more moment yep on
the additive learning and the continuum
because I think that is so interesting
continuity so with the additive and the
continued continuty it's as though when
we not only when we get the paperback
that we have a grade on it are we then
we we're already breaking the continuity
because we had to wait a couple they see
at the paperback but also then is the
additive learning they're as in do we
take what the next moment of the
educational process is and do we seize
it and go and get excited about it and
go and pursue it so it depends on an
individual child there's some children
who will continue their hunger to do
that there are others who will be like
you know okay so what's the big deal
right it depends on what kind of
background they're coming from what kind
of mindset they have and so you know in
that that seems like a very important
time to interject to say that the parent
is actually such a vital role an adult
and it an adult but but is from almost
everybody on the planet most people it's
it's specifically the parent the parents
responsibility if you birth the child
into the world it is it's for foremost
your responsibility and the communities
together but your specifically is to
inspire the child with all the different
opportunity that's available you're
absolutely right okay it is the parents
responsibility but let's be honest okay
there are parents in this world who
cannot do this for whatever reason right
you could say they come from a place of
not being able to help the child they
can come from they don't know what to do
with their child they don't you know
they did probably didn't go through the
formal situation system themselves my
father for example was the first in his
generation and his family ever to go and
do a degree in math okay he didn't have
any role models so how are we supposed
to now he was driven but how is every
child supposed to do that because
probably if the parents are you know
kind of struggling to make ends meet so
I don't want to put the blame on on the
parents and not give them that kind of
you know responsibility but let's think
about this if there is a teacher and
I've seen teacher that's what kind of
fascinated me and God means drop me into
education I saw the best teacher who
knew every child in her classroom but
there aren't that many of them she knew
exactly she would keep folders on each
child what they knew what they were you
know how to excite them how to make
something happen for them so a lot of it
was project-based a lot of it as passion
maze and give them a purpose in life
right that's a tall thing to do for
every child yes and you can't put that
on the parents all the time yes I think
if you're in a position you owe it to
your [ __ ]
to do that if you're going to bring a
child in but at some point if a parent
can do it society needs to step in me
because we're in all this together yes
so if you're going to have a school
system we need to find the best way to
make sure a child can learn and you know
what we keep saying change their mindset
changing mindset is the hardest thing to
do yes it's so hard right there are you
know there's a whole push you know
there's a whole movement about mindset
I'm a big believer of mindset but to
change people from where they are to
where you want them to be it's very
difficult so let's let's let's work our
way in into into the adaptive learning
by saying this so we have both the the
parent takes lots of responsibility for
the child so does the community that
teachers around the child to provide
lots of opportunity for the child to
actualize into that what you what you've
built enables more continuity so that
the child when they're when they're
using your platform are able to get
instant feedback about what the what
they're learning and how they're
learning it and you you've created
you